okay
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
uh history of science and technology q a
so i see we already have a whole bunch
of questions here um some may have been
saved over from last week
um let me see what should we try and
tackle first
there's a question here from mikhail
what is the history of the discovery of
black holes
all right let's talk about that so
actually the story of black holes i
think goes back a long way
see what is a black hole a black hole is
something where effectively light can't
escape from it because there's too much
gravity
and so for example we look at the earth
we say how fast you have to go to escape
from the earth what is the escape
velocity of the earth
the answer is 25 000 miles an hour
what's the escape velocity of the sun i
think it's about 100 000 miles an hour
what's the escape velocity of the galaxy
i think it's about a million miles an
hour
it's um uh things of different
masses and different sizes have
different escape velocities
and i think laplace back uh even maybe
in the
1700s perhaps had identified the fact
that you could imagine
a star that had so much mass
in such a compact area that its escape
velocity would more
be more than the velocity of light and
so then the speed of light and so then
that would mean that you could have this
thing and even light couldn't escape
from it so uh that was kind of an idea
that existed there
okay so that was the kind of the
pre-history to the to the study of black
holes
then um in uh
the kind of the theory of gravity well
that
that was that was based on newton's
theory of gravity so one of the big
things that newton did in 1687 when he
published his principia mathematica
was to make a proposal for a
mathematical theory
of how gravity works i mean people had
had the general notion that
things fall under gravity galileo had
various uh points to make about
the mass the inertial mass versus
gravitational mass
you know aristotle it had a very simple
thing to say about gravity which is that
sort of
things tend to want to be closer to the
center of the earth
and that's why they fall but newton had
a mathematical theory
of gravity and his universal law of
gravitation
was the idea that there is an inverse
square law that the the force of
attraction
between objects due to gravity is one
over the distance between them squared
and you know i find it somewhat
interesting that that universal law
sometimes even got applied in fields
completely different from
physics um i know in geography for a
while
there was sort of a lure of retail
gravitation which said you know people
who are coming to different shopping
centers you know
how far away how much will they be
pulled towards
one shopping center or another and
obviously that's not actually a force of
gravity but sort of interesting
that these other areas adopted i think
perhaps a little bit by mistake
this kind of universal word the
universal law of gravitation
but newton what the universal meant was
it applies to the sun versus the earth
versus things falling on the earth
versus a comet orbiting you know in the
solar system
universal in that sense universal
between all bodies with mass
whether they are terrestrial or whether
they are uh
whether they're whether they're in in
the sort of broader universe so to speak
so anyway
newton's theory of gravity had been the
one that uh
had been used from from 1687
um until uh until the beginning of the
1900s
and and by the way uh you know it's an
interesting story i think i've perhaps
told it before that you know when you
ask the question
is the theory right newton certainly
figured out things about the orbits of
comets and things based on that theory
but the big prize
and the big prize for mathematical
physics through the 1800s
was the theory of the moon the theory of
the motion of the moon and the
gravitational attraction of the earth
and the sun and other planets on the
moon
and could that correctly account for the
motion of the moon and things like when
eclipses would occur
very hard problem we now kind of suspect
it's sort of a computationally
irreducible problem
but then it was just a hard problem with
a lot of math that had to be figured out
to make it work
and newton when he first tried to do
this in 1687
got the wrong answer and he knew he got
the wrong answer he didn't know why he
got the wrong answer as it turned out
later
it was a question of what approximations
you use etc etc etc and it took
you know a a couple of centuries to
really work through
and get to uh uh get to the right right
result
but anyway so theory of gravity based on
newton's inverse square law laplace had
noticed that that you could have these
sort of uh things where light couldn't
escape
then we go into the beginning of the
1900s
and the question then was did anybody
need a new theory of gravity
in the beginning of the 1900s not really
newtonian gravity was working absolutely
a-okay but then einstein
in his special theory of relativity in
1905
kind of realized that that one should
think about space and time
differently than they had been thought
about before in particular in trying to
sort of reconcile maxwell's equations
for electromagnetism
with mechanics he realized that you
really had to change the definitions of
space and time and
we kind of think we understand in recent
times with our physics project
a little bit more about how that works
but nevertheless einstein
had this uh idea that you had to be able
to not
just have a fixed notion of of distances
in space but they had to be
things where depending on what reference
frame you're using which could be
a question of how fast you're going
things like that you get different
answers
okay but then uh einstein was curious
sort of how did gravity relate to all of
this
and in special relativity he had this
idea
that different reference frames if
you're traveling at different speeds
you kind of can't tell the difference
between
if you're in sort of a closed box you're
just doing your experiments and so on
you can't tell how absolutely fast
you're going
it's always the same inside that closed
box not relative to anything else
physics always looks the same regardless
of what reference frame
for example how fast you're going
okay so then he wondered about gravity
and so what he came up with was kind of
an analog of his principle of relativity
which
pretty much said you can't tell how fast
you're going wanted something analogous
to that and so he came up with this
principle of equivalence
which said you can't tell whether you're
accelerating
or whether you're in a gravitational
field that a gravitational field is kind
of
something that is something related to
the description of space and time
that's just to do with your state of
acceleration
rather than being need to be needing to
be talked about as a thing in itself
and so that led to the theory of general
covariance
and it led off to some flapping around
in 1915
einstein came up with his general theory
of relativity which is a description
of space and and space time
and the main main point of it is to say
that
space-time space can be curved in
response to the presence of energy
momentum or the presence of mass
in space so you know in the first
approximation
sort of when you when you have a uh
let's say a light beam a
photon traveling a laser something like
this
it'll go in a straight line but the
question is what does straight mean
and the question is can is space can
space be curved
in such a way that the quote straight
line
the shortest path between two points the
gd6 between two points
is something which at least looked at
from the outside would look curved and
we certainly know that if we were to
have you know i don't know some
some rubber sheet and we were to sort of
press down on the rubber sheet
we would have the paths that things
would take
to be shortest bars on the rubber sheet
would would deflect
around the place where we sort of press
down on the rubber sheet
okay so then what einstein suggested in
his
in the einstein equations is that the
curvature
is proportional to the amount of energy
momentum in
in space and so that's the basic form of
einstein's
equations and general theory of
relativity and it says
space gets more curved when there's more
mass in it
and the curvature of space then leads to
the deflection
of anything that goes through space and
so that is
how gravity is derived and it actually
works the same way in our
in our recent fundamental theory of
physics um although the
the the way that the structure of space
works is different
um but the basic idea that there's sort
of the curvature in space
that leads to deflection of sort of test
particles or leads to
leads to something which seems like a
force of gravity
um that deflects things you can
interpret it as a force of gravity
deflecting things
or you can interpret it as a as a
curvature a defamation in space-time
okay so that was in 1915 einstein
came up with this general theory of
relativity nobody really knew if it was
correct at that time
um it was certainly mathematically
elegant david hilbert
kind of uh really weak by week as
einstein was deriving
the general theory of relativity they
were kind of uh both working on very
related things so that's why it gets
called the einstein hilbert action
that's the form of the the uh the thing
that you minimize
in number extreme eyes in working out uh
how how relativity works and cultural
space time
okay so then very soon after einstein
published his equations
people started trying to figure out okay
so what are the solutions these
equations like
um famously one feature of those
equations is that
their most immediate form says the
universe should expand
and einstein was like but the universe
is obviously not expanding
so he has to have to put in an extra
term so-called cosmological time
or cosmological constant that kept the
universe from expanding it's kind of a
hack
to keep the universe from expanding now
uh
maybe 15 years later edwin hubble
observed that
there was actually a doppler shift of
the light coming from distant galaxies
so he showed the universe actually was
expanding
and uh that was sort of a it's a lesson
to those of us who try and make theories
of things
that uh the elegant theory might
actually be right and you should
ask whether the experiment uh has even
been done
before you start hacking your theory to
make it agree with what you think must
be true based on experiments that maybe
haven't even been done
so in any case that was uh but but so
that was one sort of prediction of the
einstein equations
now by i think by 1916 carl
schwarzschild
had found a solution to the einstein
equations a spherical symmetric solution
asking the question if you kind of have
a bunch of mass somewhere
what will be the gravitational field
associated with that mass
it's the same kind of question you could
ask for newtonian gravity and actually
uh in many respects you get the same
answer
okay so schwarzschild had this solution
unfortunately
was killed in world war one um the uh
uh but he had the solution i already
said okay
fine it's a solution to the equations if
you have a massive object this
determines
uh for the spherically symmetric case
what the gravitational field will be
all good uh okay there was a weird thing
though about the solution
which was that in the actual
mathematical formula for the solution
there was a singularity that is there's
a term
that where the where the actual metric
tensor the actual thing that specifies
distances based on coordinates and so on
goes to infinity
and everybody said well we don't really
know what this is but don't worry about
it
it's probably such just some
mathematical glitch
and that's the way things were until
pretty much the 1940s
and at that time people started studying
the actual collapse of stars people had
better understanding by that time
of stars operating by nuclear fusion
things like this
uh famously robert oppenheimer and
snyder
worked on um the the oppenheimer snyder
model
of um the sort of the collapse of stars
uh thought to be relevant for things
like supernovas and so on
and when they did that they kind of
pulled back out
all these questions about uh okay so
what really happens in einsteinian
gravity
um in that case uh and
um the uh
um the thing that um
uh so but it wasn't really known that
the
the you know the the schwarzschild
solution was there it had this weird
singularity
nobody really knew what that was by the
way that singularity
uh was somehow uh sort of related to
the idea that um uh the the old laplace
idea that there could be
sort of a a more than speed of light
kind of uh escape velocity those kinds
of things
but um you know there was kind of a you
know what would actually happen when a
star collapses
and when there is a a total amount of
mass that ends up being
larger than um uh the the
in that that where this amount of mass
is collected within the so-called
farcher radius
um of the of the black hole of the of
the of the
of the gravitating object i shouldn't
say black hole yet
so okay so that's where things stood at
that time and people started
trying to make measurements of you know
was einstein's theory of gravity correct
there had been one particular
measurement that had been made in 1919
of the bending of light around the sun
made by arthur eddington and friends
um in which einstein gravity had
predicted that light
would be bent a factor of two more than
newtonian gravity said it would be bent
and that was a validated result but uh
so far as i remember there were no other
direct tests of einstein gravity for
many many years
after that but anyway so people were
then starting to think about collapsing
stars
but there was still sort of then it was
confusing about this
uh coordinate singularity then people
realized
it was just a singularity in the
mathematics it wasn't a real
nothing really happened there well kind
of nothing really happened
but actually something did happen
because that was the place where sort of
light couldn't escape from it
it was a thing which later got called an
event horizon
a place where things can have an effect
from the outside can have an expect
in but from the inside can't have an
effect going out
but people were very confused about what
that singularity versus event horizon
and so on might be
it took until the 1960s i think before
uh let's see it was these things called
crisco coordinates i certainly knew
martin crystal a bit
um and uh i think those were developed
maybe the 1950s or 19 even the early
1960s
was a way of setting up coordinates so
that you didn't have this sort of
this immediate singularity and you could
kind of a little bit more effectively
analyze what was happening in this
situation
and it really took until a lot of
analysis by people like roger penrose
and so on
of just what really happens what are the
ways that things from the outside can
have an effect in from the inside can
have an effect out
to establish this idea that there would
be event horizons
that there will be these this this thing
that in the in the black hole
there would be an event rise and the
term black hole i think john wheeler
suggested that term as kind of a little
bit of a
of a you know you can't be serious this
isn't a real thing kind of kind of term
and nobody knew whether an actual
collapsing star
would form a black hole or whether mata
in the sense that it would form an event
horizon and would have this feature
that nothing could escape from it and so
on um or whether
mata as mata actually is would always
bounce
you know the star was collapsing
collapsing collapsing but maybe when
when the force of gravity was so strong
things would always bounce that would
just be a feature of the
of the so-called equation of state for
mata nobody knew
and um and that wasn't even up until the
1980s that was not known
it wasn't really known uh you know
people
imagined that um uh
there was a critical mass and you could
uh
above which you would form a black hole
but nobody really knew nobody knew the
dynamics of how that would work
and people wondered would it be a
spherical collapse with the things spurt
out in
in different directions all these kinds
of things
and um so it was all a bit mysterious
and it didn't um uh
let's see it didn't help that the whole
idea of the schwarzschild solution to
the einstein equations
it's very confusing because the
schwarzschild solution
is a vacuum solution to the einstein
equations even though
you're told oh it's a solution for some
spherical symmetric thing that's like a
star
there's no star inside there's nothing
inside the schwarzschild solution
there's this event horizon but inside
everything is just hunky-dory
until you get to the very center of this
spherically symmetric thing
at which point there is a singularity in
uh the curvature
and so in a sense in the way that the
standard general relativity is set up
that's a place where you're essentially
punching a hole out of the universe
and you're saying our equations don't
apply just in this tiny little hole in
centers that was a very confusing thing
and you know whether you can now it
could be the case that there are sort of
fragments of of uh of of crushed star
inside this thing which on the outside
is governed by the schwarzschild
solution
but it turns out it doesn't matter
whether there's crushed star inside
there
whether there's just this hole punched
out of the universe at the center
you still get the same results for what
the gravitational field looks like
outside so that was all
very confusing and i certainly was not
sure that black holes existed
um in the 1980s it was really unclear
uh whether that would actually be be a
real thing
and so for example there was a a star
cygnus x1
it was an x-ray emitting star and the
theory was that cygnus x1
was a binary star system where there was
a
maybe maybe just a single starage in
that case where
where if there is a black hole then
mata kind of spirals into the black hole
and as it spirals
in as it gets closer and closer to the
event horizon and so on it has more and
more
it's going faster and faster and that
causes it to emit
more and more radiation even to the
point where it's emitting x-rays
and so that was sort of a theory for
what cygnus x1 was
was a matter an accretion disk around a
black hole spiraling into the black hole
but it didn't really matter that it was
a black hole it could have been
some neutron star or something like this
some other thing which wasn't
really a true black hole in the einstein
relativity sense
now meanwhile during that period of time
there have been all kinds of let's
modify einstein gravity
for this reason and that reason and
there was the so-called parametrized
post-newtonian
framework which was a way of sort of
describing perturbations to einstein
gravity
um that could exist and people were
looking for
uh when spacecraft went out in the solar
system would there be deviations
from what you would expect there um
there were some uh
nice experiments precision experiments
done with satellites
um looking for various kinds of effects
um that were predicted by general
altivity and general relativity kept on
getting check marks it kept on working
they kept on being other theories that
were like oh a bit more complicated than
general relativity
different general relativity kept on
working
when people started thinking about the
quantum theory of gravity
uh people in that was particularly true
i would say in the
in the late 1950s early 1960s there'd
been a lot of success with quantum
electrodynamics
which was involved kind of looking at
photons and virtual photons
as the sort of carriers of
electromagnetic force so the obvious
question was could there be gravitons
which are
carriers of the gravitational force and
uh a bunch of people including my friend
dick feynman
looked a bunch at could you just make a
theory that was like quantum
electrodynamics but for gravitons
and different people had different
theories about this and there were all
kinds of sort of technical issues that
came up
in that theory particularly to do with a
phenomenon of re-normalizability
which had been found to very nicely deal
with the infinitives and quantum
electrodynamics
the same approach didn't work for
gravitational theories
and there were funky things like for
example john wheeler dick feynman's
thesis advisor among other things and
the inventor of the term black hole i
think
um was uh uh wrote this whole book about
what he called geometric dynamics
and uh in some ways it was a precursor
to some things that i've worked on
to do with the discreteness of space
time and things like this and had some
very nice analogies and i was always
curious why this book
was so obscure because it seemed like it
must have introduced some
some quite interesting ideas and i
finally recently with some difficulty
got myself a copy of this book
and here's the reason it's so obscure it
had the theory
that gravitons were neutrinos which is
completely wrong
so neutrinos of these particles that
were discovered were suggested by
by paulie in the 1940s i guess
um as a feature of nuclear beta decay
and then were
were first actually detected in the
late 50s or early 60s um
and uh the idea that they're very weakly
interacting particles that will like go
all the way through the earth without
interacting and
um uh this book by john wheeler is a
is a book that has a lot of interesting
things in it but it has this completely
wrong
idea that gravitons might be neutrinos
um so it's kind of a lesson in factoring
one some
uh one's kind of ideas in the sense that
the other ideas there about discrete
space-time are perfectly valid ideas
but the idea about gravitons and
neutrinos is not a valid idea
in any case so so it was all a rather
confusing thing
but then the notion of kind of the
mathematics of black holes
got better and better developed and
people started studying
the mathematical structure of the
solutions einstein's equations and so on
and started establishing that the
schwarzschild solution and the ker
solution
just for rotating black holes were in
some sense sort of the all you needed
and there weren't other
details about oh you might have a star
that has a weird little elongated shape
and does that have an effect on the
black hole that forms and the answer is
probably no
um and so on and so on and so on now
another thing that happened
in 1980 boy you guys are really
pushing me on dates here i think 1973 if
i remember right
was um stephen hawking uh came up with
this idea of hawking radiation
which when i first heard about it i was
like
huh who knows whether this is correct or
not
because the theory of gravity and black
holes and so on is a classical theory
as a as a classical physics theory it
has nothing to do with quantum mechanics
and the description of what happens in
the event horizon around black hole it's
all classical physics
what stephen hawking did was to say well
what happens if you have a quantum field
which has its quantum field fluctuations
and it's happening right close to the
event horizon or black hole but the
event horizon is still described
classically
and and sort of the qualitative picture
is you will have these particle
anti-particle pairs that are
spontaneously being created in the
vacuum
and maybe one of the members of that
pair will be pulled into the black hole
into the event horizon
leaving a kind of a lone other member of
the pair
which can no longer annihilate with with
the thing that got pulled into the black
hole and so that lone member
will escape to infinity and that will be
radiation from a black hole
and so i had no idea if that was really
right or whether
when you did a more accurate rendition
of
the event horizon of a black hole
including quantum effects
whether there'd be little fluctuations
in the event horizon which would always
keep
on uh you know whenever there was a pair
formed it would keep on
you know the event horizon would kind of
fluctuate to the point where that
both that member of that pair would
always be either on one side or the
other it was completely unobvious
whether that calculation that stephen
hawking made was in fact a physically
correct calculation
or whether it was just something you got
by putting
you know one approximation on top of
another approximation to give you an
example of something back in maybe 1981
or so
i did this calculation of uh the effect
of vacuum fluctuations
not in the case of a of a background
gravitational field
but if you just put the vacuum
fluctuations in a box
so let's say a metal box you put the
fluctuations in that box
and you say what effect does that have
on the box and it turns out
the presence of vacuum fluctuations
between like parallel plates
produces a small force of attraction
between the plates essentially because
there are more fluctuations outside the
plates than inside you do that inside a
box you get all kinds of weird effects
it later became clear that the the stuff
i'd worked out
um had the consequence that you could
actually extract
energy from the vacuum by just changing
the shapes of these boxes and so on
but it was an approximation based on
taking a classical box
and a quantum field inside and i never
believed that result
because i always thought that anything
funky that happened there
would be a consequence of the
approximation you'd made with the
classical box
and it turns out probably that's the
case that the the box
sort of can't be opaque to sufficiently
high energy radiation
and so that's why uh it doesn't it
doesn't approximation but
what people imagined with hawking
radiation or what what stephen hawking
imagined was
in the case of the of event horizons for
some reason
there wouldn't be any of this sort of uh
mismatch of approximations and the
effect will be real
now nobody observed that effect at the
beginning people noticed that
if there was a uh about a 10 to the 15
kilogram i think uh black hole formed at
the beginning of the universe
i think that's a mass about the size of
mount everest or something
such black holes would be exploding so
the way hawking radiation works
it sort of is very very gradual for a
long time and it as the black hole gets
smaller and smaller it gets
more and more intense until eventually
there's sort of this burst of radiation
at the end of the black hole so to speak
and people imagine that maybe that would
be observed of primordial black holes
from the beginning of the universe but
it wasn't and so hawking radiation
you know to to sort of uh spoiler
hooking radiation has never been
observed
so we don't know whether hawking
radiation really happens
although at this point the theory is
sufficiently well developed
that it probably does and by the way
somewhat confusingly
there is a similar kind of variation
from acceleration
um that uh maybe has been observed
in in in particle experiments although
it's sort of controversial
what the interpretation is but any case
so back to black holes so it was
it was then you know people said oh well
there must be lots of black holes and
there were more
things identified with things like
cygnus x1 identified
there's this idea oh they're probably
black holes in the center of our galaxy
there might be big black holes
in the center of a galaxy but it was all
a bit unclear
and it was a bit unclear whether a thing
with just a lot of mass
is different from a formal black hole in
einstein's theory
with all of these event horizons and all
these other features
and i have to say it wasn't for me until
gravitational waves were detected
about five years ago that i finally got
convinced that black holes are actually
real
and the way i got convinced is that the
way that computation works it really
depends on the fact that there are two
black holes and they merge
into one spherical black hole and it's
not obvious that would happen
and it's not something that if it wasn't
something for which the formal sort of
notion of event horizons and so on
really worked
it's not clear that that would would go
that way and so
to observe that and to observe the
little ring down as the
as you make this kind of bell-like thing
that is kind of
like you you hit the thing you hit the
black hole and it wobbles around a
little bit like a bell
and it emits gravitational waves i mean
it sounds very peaceful but actually
it uh in in a few seconds one and a half
times the mass of our sun was converted
into energy
and the result of that in gravitational
radiation was
detectable by us a third of the way
across the universe so it wasn't a
particularly peaceful
event um but in any case the the um
uh by the way just in the last month or
so we've we've got um
results from our model of physics that
give the exact same
uh kind of ring down for a for a black
hole computed using using our model of
physics so
that's interesting as well but in any
case so
the discovery of black holes was a bit
of an interesting mess
because the sort of mathematical belief
that something like that might exist
was but was it a was it an artifact of
the mathematics was it real
this took a long time to resolve and i
would say that it's only
only quite recently that it's really
clear that that's right and and for
example the
the full scope of where black holes are
important is still not known
i mean i remember back in probably 1975
i remember
going to some talk and some i was i was
young then but um
going to some talk given by some uh
fairly well-known physicist and i i
asked the question afterwards you know
i was a talk about black holes i guess
and i asked the question
uh could particles like electrons be
black holes
oh no that's a very silly idea you know
couldn't possibly be irrelevant
etc etc etc turns out it might actually
be true
but um so uh but that's
that's a very different sort of
interpretation of a black hole like
thing
from from them what one imagined which
was it's all collapsing stars and things
of that kind
or it's just features of mathematics and
it wasn't just wasn't clear
whether it was physical or whether it
was just a feature of the mathematics i
mean
there are plenty of situations in which
there are kind of features of
mathematics that say
something but they're not real they're
just a consequence of for example the
particular choice of coordinates you've
made
and it's not something which when you
actually observe it
physically will be there so anyway long
long discussion to about um the history
of black holes
and um i think the um uh the sort of the
quantum effects
around for black holes not yet observed
in our models there are some some
particular kinds of predictions about
that
that might conceivably be observable but
so far
so far the the the best we know is that
when black holes merge
they seem to do it in the way that
general sovereignty says very accurately
so
um and uh it's always a a sign for
physical theories
when okay so there's one thing when
there's kind of an easy prediction
and you say okay given my theory i can
immediately predict the following will
be true
okay given my theory of the inverse
square law of gravity
i can kind of immediately predict that
the that the trajectories will be conic
sections like ellipses and things like
this
uh well somewhat immediately there's a
little bit of math involved
but in a sense the theory gets more
points
the deeper the math that's involved to
get to the prediction
so you know sometimes because it kind of
feels like
you didn't it wasn't a put up job in the
following sense
if you have a theory where underneath
the theory there's something
that says oh there's this particular
thing you work it out and then you go
through
all this work all this work and then you
say okay i predict the following
you go and measure it and that's what
you actually discover that seems very
convincing because it seems like you
didn't put that effect in from the
beginning
it just was something that emerged from
the structure of the theory
it's kind of uh it's almost it reminds
me of sort of clinical trials where
you know is it an effect where the where
the patient knows they got the placebo
or not
well you can't control this thing you
just start off with your little theory
and then you work out all this fancy
stuff and then you say at the end of it
do you get the right answer
so general relativity does really well
from that point of view because it's
really hard to work things out
you know the actual computation of a
black hole merger is a complicated thing
people end up using our wolfram language
technology stack to work out all kinds
of things about sort of the symbolic
description of the the tensor
expressions and so on and then
eventually
it turns into a big numerical analysis
adventure
to work out the final details um but so
this idea there's a big tower to get
from the theory to the
prediction gets you a lot more points
and you know in our theory for example
now
those towers are going to be pretty big
and of course somebody has to do the
experiment and they have to come out
right
but that will be very high leverage um
results because because there is so
little going in
so much work to get to the prediction
and then sense so much that comes out
um but that's uh okay so anyway that
that's a little bit about the story of
of um
of black holes and i think uh you know
one of the remaining mysteries about
black holes
is i mentioned that at the center of a
schwarzschild black hole there's the
singularity in spacetime this this point
that's punched out in the universe so to
speak
well presumably at least in the formal
version of the mathematics of that
and occur black hole a rotating black
hole that was a solution to the einstein
equations it was discovered much later
maybe even 1960s
that to represent something that has a
uh hazard momentum
um in a curved black hole uh there's an
event horizon it's a bit more
complicated there are two event horizons
but
basically there's an event horizon that
doesn't let effects from inside the
black hole
ever get out unless the black hole is
spinning really fast
if the black hole if the angle momentum
j in some units is larger than the mass
m then there will be a naked singularity
you will be able without an event
horizon shielding it
you'll be able to actually sort of see
in from the outside world to that
singularity to that place
where there's something broken in the
universe so to speak well
turns out when you look at black holes
that are observed
there seem to be a bunch that have more
or less critical angular momentum but
none that seem to have super critical
angular momentum that kind of suggests
that somehow there's some mechanism
that shields the naked singularities
that prevents naked singularities from
forming
now you might think in terms of the
history story i told
well okay so there's a mechanism that
prevents naked singularities for me
you know back in the past it's a very
detailed thing that well you can form a
black hole
but you can't form a rapidly spinning
black hole so
it wasn't obvious you could form a black
hole it might have just bounced
and it's now believed that you can't
form a rapidly spinning black hole
and in fact this question about native
similarities there is some very
elaborate construction that allows you
to get sort of
something that's like a naked
singularity but one of the things that
we suspect from our theories is that the
presence of an acid singularity
requires kind of a a sufficiently
complex description of space-time
that it's not possible for a
computationally bounded observer
to have such a description and that's
why you don't get this
but that's um you know that's another
wrinkle in the whole story of black
holes
is they imply singularities and space
time they imply basically what they're
basically
saying once again it's a very weird
thing the einstein equations
are supposed to be equations for
space-time and yet the einstein
equations are announcing to you
sorry we don't work at this point and
that's a very weird thing
and it does happen with other kinds of
equations um
but it is something where you know it's
like you have to be a little bit
suspicious you've got these equations
that are supposed to describe space-time
and yet they put up a flag and say we
don't work in this place
and how do you interpret that and that
was a long story to get to the point
where people feel comfortable with that
interpretation
may be too comfortable with that
interpretation and there's sort of more
story to be had so for example
in our models we can actually study the
formation of supercritical black holes
black holes that are spinning faster
than their mass so to speak and uh what
happens in our models is something very
bizarre
that you couldn't see in general
relativity what happens is
in our models a piece of the universe
simply breaks off
and in general relativity the universe
space-time is described by this
manifold that doesn't have the
possibility that it can change its
topological structure so to speak it
can't break off it can't change its
dimensions and so on but in our models
we can explicitly see
in this case that things break off and
so hopefully we'll be able to analyze a
little bit
what happens to various kinds of black
hole mergers and so on and when
things can break off a very weird
phenomenon um and and get
sort of a more physicalized description
of what's going on
when the einstein equations just say
well this is what we conclude but we
can't really give you a physical
mechanism for what's happening
all right long answer to that question
interesting question thank you
okay so many more
questions here um
let's see so question from
idiod is gravitator electromagnetism
sufficient to
get black holes without horizon so do
you need the full general relativity
uh i think you need full general
relativity i think um
a charged black hole rising a nordstrom
black hole has yet more
tentacles to it but but you basically
just need the einstein equations
to get event horizons
um
okay there are questions here about um
um
okay a few more questions on the sort of
gravitational um
uh direction paul menendez asks um
uh did i even ever meet stephen hawking
or chandrasekhar yes i certainly did
meet stephen hawking
i met him right at the time you know he
had um
uh als neurological disease
um for many many years survived just
uh a very very long time but i met him
right at the time when he was
still just about able to talk but it was
really hard to understand and that was
in the um
one must that have been that must have
been
[Music]
1980-ish
and um i always uh
i i i thought that um one of his
you know impressive personal
achievements was just he just had this
terrible
neurological disease which made it
difficult for him to
uh to communicate and to do sort of the
the ordinary things people
people end up doing and he ended up
persisting i mean he was
a person with a strong personality i
would say who ended up
persisting in in doing physics um
rather than just sort of giving up on
the whole thing um which was certainly
an impressive feature
i mean i do remember when when back and
it must have been 1980 or so
uh pointing out him that there were all
these kind of computational methods that
you could use to
you know to be able to type even though
you couldn't uh
you know even with paralysis and so on
and i was a bit surprised he wasn't that
interested in that stuff at that time i
mean he always had a group of kind of
humans assisting him um later on i think
he got much more
involved in in using technological
solutions and so on
um and uh uh that was that was a good
thing to see
uh chandrasekhar uh who is the person
who um
uh studied a lot the kind of stability
of
of collapsing matter and things like
this i was a person at the university of
chicago i never met him
um let's see
the the um
uh primaries also mentions ernst mark
who i don't know all that much about i
have to say um
mark was was interesting in the history
of mechanics
for these ideas about things like where
does mass
come from maybe mass
is the result of the effect of
gravity from all the other masses in the
universe
in the end i don't think that's really
the right picture but
it's an interesting picture and it's one
that i think influenced einstein
uh i mean mark also discussed the
question of
of rotating if you're spinning around
and how do you know you're spinning
relative to is spinning
something that is has sort of
relativistic kind of
consequences and i guess again i've i've
not really
uh have less understanding of that than
i might there are some weird solutions
einstein's equations
that involve spinning universes that
have all kinds of
all kinds of strange effects
particularly close time-like curves
that is being able to essentially travel
in time like you do in space
something which i don't think is
possible given our current models of
physics which very much distinguish
space from time i mean what one of the
things about the early history
the relativity you know in 1905
einstein kind of came up with a special
theory of relativity
which has certain mathematical features
and one of its mathematical features
is that it is full of x squared minus uh
uh
uh minus c squared t squared it's
that particular form distance minus
speed of light squared times time
squared
it shows up all over the place and in
1909 a chap called hermann minkowski
was a mathematician primarily a number
theorist sort of got hold of that
that kind of uh structure and said yes
we can make a geometry
around this kind of relativistic notion
of space
and time and he said and that geometry
looks just like what he'd studied in
theory of quadratic forms in number
theory and so
in that very nice very mathematically
elegant geometry
space and time become the same kind of
thing
because they enter in sort of the same
way in this formulae and so on and so
that led to this idea
of space-time and time is just a
dimension like space and it led to
endless you know time travel type
stories although h.g wells's time travel
book i think
time machine book predated that
discussion it was in the late 1800s
um but i think the um this this kind of
idea of minkowski is that from a matter
of mathematical elegance
um kind of led to this whole space and
time the same kind of thing
which led to a whole development in
physics that i think went off track
because i think what has become clear
from our models of physics
is that time is associated with sort of
the inexorable computation of future
states of the universe
and space is associated with just
extension of kind of the data structure
that represents the universe
now actually i was just i i just wrote a
piece about
about consciousness and so that's led me
into
a bunch of interactions with uh
philosophers and so on i was just uh
exchanging meow with a philosopher i
know who actually of all strange things
know from elementary school but
he's become a distinguished philosopher
um
the uh and um he was pointing out that
this notion that time is different from
space that actually
aristotle already had a notion of time
being associated with transformations of
things
which is pretty much the same idea as
our idea of time being associated with a
progressive computation in the universe
so it's kind of one of these cases of
where yeah well the obvious thing turns
out to be right
i mean uh you know a lot of what
aristotle said
about physics for example turns out not
to be not to be really on the mark
um but this is sort of an obvious
observation about what time is and
seems like that's pretty much what time
is and
the uh the sort of the mathematical
elegance of what mikowski did that led
to minkowski space and
all these kinds of constructs and
relativity um seem to kind of have led
people a bit astray
and it's kind of a lesson in history of
science of uh sometimes it's
you know i was talking about you know if
you have an elegant theory go with it
but sometimes the elegance can lead you
astray
and you could be led to an analogy which
isn't really a correct analogy
so let's see um
all right there was a question here
oh boy there's a question at the end
here about
um uh but i want to i want to address a
few others here but but
there's another um um
this question from frost is there an
instance of phenomenon where an
instrument
uses a theory and it's just something
like girdles theory that applies to
instruments in physics the
answer is very much yes it relates to
this idea of computational
irreducibility
that i've studied a lot that has to do
with
how do you know what's going to happen
in a system in physics
well one thing you can do is just sort
of look at the underlying rules of the
system and just follow them
step by step another thing you can do
which is what
sort of mathematical science has led one
to come to expect is
i'll just work out the formula for the
answer and then
i don't have to go through all those
individual steps the system itself has
to go through
i just sort of fill in a parameter to
the formula and i get the result
and computational irreducibility which
is closely related to girdle's theorem
is the statement that you often can't do
that so for example if you want to say
will it
ever will the system ever do this the
answer will be you just can't tell
because you it is a computationally
irreducible process
and ever is a long time an infinite time
and to know whether that could ever
happen because it's irreducible
you also have to be able to run for an
infinite time
so okay let's uh let's see okay here's a
fun one that i'm not sure i'm going to
be able to say that much about but um
might be fun from mikhail again uh
what is the history of ufo observations
so um uh
you know i think people unidentified
flying
objects uh kind of have we been visited
by the extraterrestrials
and have they come in flying saucers and
so on has a
um as a fun history i i don't know when
the first of those things happened but
but i have to believe you know if you
think about the history of flight
done by humans right there were balloons
um
back you know hot air balloons and so on
back
the montgolfier brothers was
[Music]
late 1700s maybe maybe i'm getting that
wrong something like that
um i think uh uh you know people are
sending over paris and these very
decorated balloons and so on so people
could have started talking about
unidentified flying objects around that
time
i suspect um i i don't think i've heard
of them
um the uh um
um the thing that um
uh was some uh
people i think started really talking
about those kinds of things once
airplanes were common and um then
uh the um
there's sort of been a long-running
story of
what is an unidentified flying object
you know is it a lenticular cloud
that looks like a sort of flying source
of shape and it's a weird shaped thing
and it and it relates very much to this
question about
what is artificial and what is natural
and how do you tell
and if it's something that was made by
us you know it was some
some funky military experiment well then
we expected to have all the details of
our kind of engineering although
you know if you see your average stealth
bomber or something it doesn't look much
like an ordinary plane it's got
all these very flat surfaces that that
try and avoid radar
reflections and so on and it looks
pretty weird
and if you were to see one of those
things and you didn't know at all what
had been developed in the history of our
engineering
maybe because it was secret you might
say that looks like an unidentified
flying object that must be you know
alien technology
um but uh you know there's there's this
sort of repeated thing i mean there's
the
the uh uh famous you know stories from
the 1950s i guess
of project blue book which was a us
air force i guess project to investigate
claims about ufos and there were
was a very kind of a pretty sober
scientist who got kind of pulled into
that whole thing
and um all kinds of stories about it and
you know area 54 in new mexico where
it's like you know that's that's that's
the fodder for the science fiction movie
and so on
of where the alien spaceships are kept
and all those kinds of things
but this story doesn't die i mean it
keeps on going and you know there are
things from very recent times of of uh
you know sort of recording cockpit
recordings from
from military planes about uh you know
strange objects that are moving
you know many times the speed of sound
and so on and so on and so on
again it's very much a story of what's
artificial and what's natural because
if it's terrestrial technology we know
what it's going to be like roughly
if it's something bizarre it's like
what's the difference between a
lenticular cloud
or some weird new effect some weird new
atmospheric effect
and an unidentified flying object which
kind of has
the sense of being a um uh something
with with um
um uh with sort of intentional
some pilot is that the is that the
controls type thing
so i don't think i have much more useful
to say about that than that but it is
it is interesting oh am i am i being
told area 51 i thought it was
maybe i'm um okay area 51 i guess rather
than area 54.
um why don't i get area 54 maybe that's
some
some other thing no matter the um
in any case the the thing that you know
you you have fun questions then about
okay what if there were you know
alien spacecraft in the solar system
what if there was an alien structure on
the moon
what if you know how can you tell and
you get into these very complicated
questions about you know
how do you even tell that there's
there's intelligent life on earth you
know
when i was writing the new kind of
science book i was curious about that
question and i asked some astronauts i
know you know what do you see on the
earth
that most seems like it's a sign of
intelligent life
or intelligence or something or
intentionality and
the thing they they identified actually
was in the great salt lake in utah
there's this turns out it's a railway
caused railroad
causeway that slices across the lake and
on one side the algae are one color on
the other side the algae are another
color
and there's a straight line that crosses
between those two and there's been sort
of a long history of
you know what do you put as a feature on
the earth so that the aliens
can um uh can recognize it i think gauss
for example
suggested chopping down trees in the
siberian forest
to be in the shape of the pythagorean
theorem so that the martians could see
that
somebody on the earth had identified the
pythagorean theorem
but you can ask kind of how would you
generalize that and as a long story
about this which i can
could tell at a different time and it's
kind of kind of interesting to see
kind of in the solar system where are
there strange geometrical things
one of my sort of favorite sort of
statements about this emanuel kant
had this uh statement if you fight
find a hexagon drawn in the sand then
you know that that must have been done
on purpose
because nothing would have nothing sort
of would naturally have created a
hexagon well it turns out
if you look at the north pole of saturn
that there is a giant storm
that is perfectly hexagonal in shape
so that's a you know that then it's is
that extraterrestrials as an
unidentified
you know it's a flying object planetary
object or something or what is that or
is it just a storm
complicated thing okay there have been a
couple of questions here about
uh uh results from the uh lh
lhc to do with bms on decays and i have
not seen this stuff so i'm going to have
to click on this link
and take a look at this okay
um
okay um
all right well i can explain what this
is about i i don't know what the i can't
discuss
the i haven't looked enough at um uh at
the actual um
uh what was discovered there
but um
okay well let's see i don't know this is
crossover between physics and
uh history of physics but okay i'll tell
you a bit of both
okay so this has to do with um uh
so-called um
has to do with the standard model of
particle physics okay let's let's go
back a little bit
so nuclear beta decay was observed when
radioactivity was discovered
um who will have discovered that
oh marie curie have discovered that
um certainly in the very early days of
well radium as an alpha emitter um i
think
maybe polonium is a beta emitter i'm not
sure um so these different kinds of
radiation
uh when when nuclei self-destruct
there's alpha radiation which is the
nucleus emits little helium four nuclei
two proton two neutron lumps or beta
decay
where it essentially emits electrons and
neutrinos as it turns out
and gamma decay where it emits photons
um
and so in the early days of
radioactivity i i
don't remember exactly when uh beta
decay was discovered
the possibility of um uh of
of um nuclei
spontaneously self-destructing and
emitting electrons
so somewhat later i think in the 1940s
if i remember correctly
the neutron was discovered to be
unstable so nuclei contain neutrons and
protons
protons so far as we can tell are
completely stable particles they have
lifetime certainly more than about 10 to
the 30th years
neutrons on the other hand have a
lifetime of about 15 minutes
and a free neutron not bound in a
nucleus
simply decays to a proton electron an
anti-neutrino
and that process is an example of beta
decay and so
then the question was what causes beta
decay what
what kind of uh what kind of
effect what kind of quantum effect what
kind of process causes beta decay
and there was sort of a phenomenological
theory of beta decay
developed in the 1950s and most
particularly was i think of the v minus
a
theory that was developed by dick
feynman and murray gilman both people i
knew pretty well
that was a theory of kind of what
the effective interaction process going
on in nuclear beta decay was
but did people didn't know sort of what
the what the cause of that decay process
was
and uh just like in earth magnetism
it was realized from from what max
planck had done in 1900 and so on and
then what einstein did a little bit
later
this idea of photons discrete particles
of of uh
electromagnetic radiation which could
then be studied from a quantum theory
point of view that was discovered in
1920s
and then the theory of quantum
electrodynamics developed and by the
1940s
it was fairly uh fairly under control
mathematically and so on
with the invention of feynman diagrams
and things like that but the question
was could a similar thing be done for
the weak nuclear force the thing that
causes nuclear beta decay
and initially it wasn't initially there
was it was just like
when you have photons in
electromagnetism you exchange
photons and they kind of that's why
there can be a force
um electromagnetic forces can be sort of
at a distance
in the case of the weak interactions
what seemed to be the case is they were
just point interactions
everything happened at a point and the
details of what happened at that point
were things that were being analyzed by
uh the v minus a is is a
vector uh kind of law which is similar
to electromagnetism and
a is the axial vector law which is
different from electromagnetism
um but that was kind of a a theory for
how this worked
well uh one of the
features so there were a number of
things that happened
uh one of them has to do with parity
violation was discovered in um
19 mid 1950s um
and uh uh so that that had to do with
the fact that
uh maybe this is let's not go in that
direction we don't need to talk about
that
the the um there were certain rules
about how
weak nuclear interactions could happen
how weak interactions occurred
actually weak interactions happened to
me my personal sort of first
uh sort of very serious foray into into
quantum field theory and things like
that and i i have to say when i was
i guess 13 years old i spent the summer
writing this long treatise on
on weak interactions which you can now
find on the web
i can't guarantee that everything in it
is correct um
it was my uh 13 to 14 year old
production
um but uh anyway the thing that i
happened to study a whole bunch
but at the time it was very much sort of
a these are the phenomena of the weak
interaction we don't really know what's
underneath
it but what were the phenomena so very
important phenomenon
was about strange particles so strange
particles
uh okay so back in the 1930s
well people had known okay so the
electron was discovered
uh right at the end of the 1800s um then
the proton was discovered in the early
1900s and then
the neutron and so on so people knew
about proton neutron electron
then uh hideki yukawa suggested that
there
should be these things called pions
which were the carriers of the strong
nuclear force that would bind nuclei
together
um then uh they were not
the first particles to actually be
discovered separately the first particle
we discovered separately was the muon
which actually has a very similar to
mass to the pion but isn't the pion
neuron is like a heavy version of the
electron was discovered in the 1930s in
cosmic rays
and uh then what happened is that um
um the um uh so
there started with this whole zoo of
elementary particles discovered
but a bunch of these particles their
decay processes even the muon for
example
it decays through the weak interaction a
muon decays into an electron and two
neutrinos
and it um and then the pion
also the pi plus and pi minus decay into
a muon and a neutrino that's their most
common decay mode
um the the k on another particle was
discovered
decays into uh typically two pions
and um the uh and so
those decay processes were examples of
the weak interaction
and what was discovered was that there
were certain rules about those decay
processes
so for example um i
should have explained that these
different kinds of particles the pions
the kaons
the proton are things of the lambda
hyper on the sigma hyperions
etc these were all particles that were
discovered in the 19 bullet it ended up
being 1950s
um and a whole bunch of these things
were discovered
um and people started realizing that you
could sort of fit these together in some
kind of um
uh some kind of sort of combinatorial
arrangements it's a little bit like what
dalton had done
in in inventing atomic theory uh with
respect to um
uh to chemistry by just sort of noticing
that
there's two of this and one of that and
so there's sort of it must be that this
is consists of these discrete elements
well so back in the day uh people like
murray gilman noticed
that for elementary particles and
realized that you could sort of fit them
together in certain ways
and and came up with this idea also my
friend george zweig was also involved in
this
in 1964 suggesting this quark theory
where you could say that all these
different elementary particles
were um were kind of could be
understood in terms of of combinations
of let's say three quarks for baryons
like protons
and a quark in an anti-quark for things
like the pie on mesons like pion
but actually even before that mary
gelman had suggested
this idea of this thing called
strangeness
and so the question is what's the
difference between something like a
lambda hyperon
and a proton neutron they kind of have
about the same mass but they're
obviously different in some way
well what he said was let's imagine that
there's a quantum number
called strangeness which is an attribute
of lambda hyperons it's also an
attribute of
of chaos um and that that is the
characterization of those things so
the feature of strangeness is in strong
interactions
like what happens inside nuclei
strangeness can't be created or
destroyed
in weak interactions strangeness can be
changed
so what that meant was there was this
phenomenon it was called associated
production
which was if you got a lambda hyper on
you also got a k on
and the reason that happened is because
the strangenesses of the lambda and the
k
would cancel each other out so the
strong interaction you get by just
smashing protons together
um would produce something which had net
zero strangeness
um and that was that that was you would
see in these bubble chamber pictures you
would see these
these two particles a lambda particle
and a k on um
being produced associatedly so to speak
and so that was kind of the
the strong interactions don't have uh
strangeness changing the weak
interactions do
so then there began to be all kinds of
different
uh rules that were discovered about um
strangeness and how it changed in
in um uh in weak interactions and so on
all of it was a bit okay so one of the
things
that happened was in addition to a
change of
uh in addition to impossible to change
strangeness
the um the weak interactions had this
feature that whenever one of them
happened
it always changed charge it didn't the
total charge would be the same
but always there will be sort of
exchange of charge between particles in
some sense
it would be um
there would be something where you would
have a a neutron
which has charge zero would turn into a
proton with charge
one and emit an electron will charge
minus one so charge was still conserved
but sort of the mainline thing that
happened was neutron charge zero turns
into proton
charge one okay so that led to the
question
were there um neutral currents
uh were there ways of having weak
interactions
that would not change charge and back
when i was first studying this in the
early 1970s
um neutral currents were like uh well we
don't think so none of them have been
observed
okay so that was so it was believed that
the the weak interactions were always
charge-changing um and i have to say as
i talked to you guys about this
i realized i have not thought about this
in 45 years
so these are i'm glad those neurons seem
to be still functioning
um the in any case uh
so okay back okay so by
back in the early 1970s how do weak
interactions happen
there was a thing called the
intermediate vector boson hypothesis
which said that just like there are
photons exchanged to make
electromagnetic forces
so there are intermediate vector bosons
exchanged to make weak forces
but the intermediate vector boson would
actually be a very
high mass object not something like a
photon which is zero mass or even a pion
which is a temp the mass or proton
be a very high mass object and the fact
that it was high mass
would account for the fact that we can
weak interactions seem to happen almost
at a point they seem to be
almost uh you know not not extended
and um the uh and so so that was
that was kind of the the idea there um
but nobody knew if that was really
correct
then eventually along came the so-called
weinberg salaam model
which became the standard model of
political physics although originally it
was called the weinberg salaam model
after steve weinberg and abdul salaam uh
both of whom i
well steve weinberg's still alive after
salaam is not
but i've known both of them um
the uh they kind of in 1967-ish proposed
this kind of model
of um of how um
uh how things might get set up how there
might be a thing
that is a little bit like
electromagnetism but not quite
that might be the um uh the thing
responsible for we contractions
and somehow one had to account for the
fact that well it's just like the photon
but it has a mass
a huge mass and the mechanism for that
mass was the higgs mechanism and there's
a whole story to that which i let me not
go into that right now
but suffice it to say eventually it
became more and more
likely from kind of the mathematics
working out nicely
that yes the w particle which was the
the sort of modern name for the
intermediate vector boson really should
exist
it was finally observed in the 1980s
and it has a mass of about 65 times the
mass of a proton
um and that was all good but this whole
theory also predicted
neutral currents that is k so the w
boson
has a charge plus or minus one um
but also a a a a neutral
particle often called the z zero or the
z
naught as i used to call it when i was
first studying these things
in british english um the uh
uh so prediction they're going to be
neutral currents
okay neutral currents had not been
observed in ordinary particle decays
there were particle decays
which could be produced by neutral
currents but
they were not observed and the neutral
currents that
would have been easiest to observe would
be strangeness changing neutral currents
okay and strangeness
changing neutral currents
would have led to decay processes which
were not observed
for example if i'm remembering and this
is from very long time ago i'm afraid
uh k goes to pi neutrino antineutrino
i think as an example of that yeah pies
k zero goes to pi zero
new new bar as an example i think um
uh gosh i wrote a whole paper about this
in 1976
but i'm afraid i have forgotten some of
the details now um
in any case the um uh okay neutral
current's not observed
the best way to observe a neutral
current would be
by a reaction that involved neutrinos
so the way neutrinos were detected
originally
was in these giant tanks of basically
cleaning fluid
where you'd have a neutrinos produced by
a nuclear reactor
and the neutrinos will be streaming
through this big tank
and just every so often with very low
probability a neutrino would interact
with a nucleus there
and the nucleus would kind of be to be
kicked by the neutrino
and you would see the effect of that
nucleus uh
as a sort of piece of radiation but that
effect
was mostly actually i'm sorry
no no the the correct thing not that
that the neutrino would would convert
into an electron into a muon
um as a result of interacting with the
nucleus and you would then observe that
electron or that muon
and so that was a charge changing
because neutrino has charged zero
the electron and muon have charge one if
that was a charge-changing
uh weak interaction so the case that is
more difficult
still is neutrino comes in and
neutrino goes out that's an example of a
neutral current interaction
so the question was were neutrino
interactions where neutrino comes in and
neutrino goes out
were they happening and it's obviously a
bit difficult to detect because the
neutrino that goes out you don't get to
see
what happens with that because it
doesn't it might not it might go through
the whole earth without interacting
again it might be just it happened to
interact once
and then it doesn't interact for a
really long time after that you can
potentially see it by looking at the
recoil of the nucleus
and things like this so turns out
so neutral currents were discovered i
think 1970
oh when was it 1976 maybe
maybe a little earlier than that um but
the embarrassing thing is
had neutral currents been looked for
earlier the experiments
that have been done at cern in the early
1960s
would have observed uh neutral currents
they just didn't look for them they
didn't know to look for them the theory
hadn't really predicted them and so and
the theory had kind of said oh no
those don't really exist there's no
reason for them to exist so nobody
looked for them
and uh um my
late friend tini veltman uh always told
the story that he told them to look for
them
but they hadn't looked for them and by
the time he told them to look for them
actually it was too late
because they had recycled the bubble
chamber film
that had been taken in the early 1960s
and had they
kept it and reanalyzed it they would
have discovered neutral currents much
earlier
okay so i believe
the thing that's being talked about here
um
is i would have to look more at this to
see
um uh let's see what is this
um to see exactly what's being talked
about but this
is um
okay
uh
this doesn't look that exciting um
i see okay so the claim here
is that um
okay if you have a b quark which is the
so strangeness was kind of a 1950s idea
then people had suggested just by virtue
of symmetry there are two quarks the
upcoke and the down quark
that show up in the proton and neutron
and those kinds of
non-strange particles then the strange
quark shows up in the strange particles
and there's sort of all possible
combinations of up down strange
make up the different particles just by
sort of by virtue of symmetry people are
suggested maybe there's also a charm
quark
that is sort of the the pair just as the
down quark goes with the up quark
so the charm cork would go to with the
uh with the strange quark
and people didn't know if that was right
then in the mid-1970s
a bunch of things were observed which
eventually
in not very long in six months or so
became clear those are evidence of charm
quarks and so
yes the charm quark really exists so
that was like
okay those exist there are two
generations of particles the up down
uh charm strange charm um and
uh but then there's also there's the
electron and there's the muon
and then another thing was discovered
uh well okay so then in 1977
i guess there was another unexpected
discovery
which was uh the b quark uh that has a
mass about five times the mass of the
proton
um and uh so then that was that was
another thing b
quarks are kind of a little bit like
strange quartz a little bit like down
quarks
and then much much later the um the top
quark was discovered which kind of is
the partner of the b
quark and that has a mass of about 173
times the mass of a proton
um and um the in any case
there's this question for the weak
interactions and the
the w particle and the z particle and so
on of what
um uh of of what kind of weak
interactions what kind of interactions
could w particles have
with uh with these different kinds of
quarks and so the the most common kind
of process is something like
up quark goes to down quark plus w
particle
that's a a charge changing reaction
um or uh some kind of cork
emits a z zero um and uh but stays as
the same kind of cork
okay so the thing that's not supposed to
happen is
that you can have a um
uh a um a z particle z zero
emitted by um as a result of
of um the um
a transition between two quarks
and so what is claimed here is that
um let's see how does this
work so what's being claimed is that
there's a decay of the b0
uh which is a a um a combination of a b
quark and uh so the b0s here
a b quark and a strange cork um to
muon mu plus mu minus i know this really
takes me back this is the kind of
particle physics i used to do
a very long time ago and boy i could
even work out this formula here i even
pretty much know this formula that um
i'm seeing in this in this document
about the the rate of the decay
from um of a b0 to mu plus mu minus
and um okay so there's apparently a
prediction here
and the claim would be that
uh let's see is there a claim here
that the results are different from what
was expected
um come on come on come on
okay this is um
uh
okay so the claim is that the rate
of the decay b0 goes to mu plus mu minus
is 2.5 times the prediction from the
standard model
that the standard model would say that
decay could only happen
through some fairly complicated process
involving i guess
two virtual w particles um and uh
there's an alternative process where it
could happen
through um
a um a direct sort of neutral current
interaction between b
quarks and strange quarks i'm seeing
here oh boy
there's a um uh
there's a kind of diagram a kind of
findment diagram that represents a weak
process
that was called a penguin diagram and
that involved two people i know
um business john ellis who's a long time
was a long time physicist at cern
and a then young person called melissa
franklin
um who was a uh
intern type person at cern and um
she had some kind of bar bet with john
ellis
that was um uh you know if you lose this
bet
you have to get the word penguin into
the next paper that you write
and so john i guess lost this bet and he
was writing this paper about weak decay
processes
and so he has this kind of feynman
diagram to represent this process
which really doesn't look anything like
a penguin but you can draw it because
it's just a graph
you can lay it out however you want you
can draw it so it kind of looks like a
penguin
and he did that and these things have
been called penguin diagrams ever since
but apparently that's that's one of the
processes for this particular decay
i mean i i would say that
in the world of of weird effects
observed in particle physics and are
they real and are they not real
it's always a complicated story because
particle physics experiments are very
difficult
they involve huge detectors with with
huge numbers of
of things that are detected at each
event you have to kind of parcel that
out
and make sure that there's no background
there's nothing you didn't expect about
oh there's this effect that causes
this to happen when this happens and so
on it's it's very difficult to
to know and i noticed here that uh it
seemed like there was an effect
about 2.5 standard deviations which is
not particularly large it's not
particularly
uh what you would expect from um uh you
know
not not particularly extreme in terms of
of what you would expect from signs of
statistical variations
um and uh um
the um uh i think this sort of question
about
um okay this is a the claim is it's now
reached three sigma
all right um yeah i i i mean i i would
say thank you for pointing this out to
me i
i love these kinds of things i back in
the day uh
you know uh weak decays were my
particular friends
um i wrote a big long review about weak
decays that had a lot of very
interesting things in it back in
1980 which i'm not sure anybody ever
read because at the time
weak decays were definitely out of
fashion um
but uh kind of the thing that is
interesting to realize is you think it's
just some random particle decaying into
other particles
but the point is what happens is because
of the way quantum field theory works
even a process which occurs at sort of
the ordinary energy scales that that
accelerators reach
or that correspond to the masses of
particles because of
virtual particle effects it can be
sensitive
to things that that are happening at
much higher energies beyond the energies
that accelerators can reach
so by looking with high precision at
these weak decays you can probe things
that are beyond what we've been able to
see in accelerators and for example
the fact that the higgs particle was
known with some considerable accuracy
uh sort of how it would behave and so on
what mass it would have and things like
that
i was a consequence of this sort of
ability to probe
processes by looking at these virtual
particle effects with high precision
experiments
so they're really worthwhile thing to do
but but this is um yeah this is a
this is exactly um the kind of uh decay
process that
um i used to enjoy so so pi zero
in fact i think i've written i think i
wrote about pi zero goes to e plus e
minus
which is the analog which is sort of
analogous to um
to what's being discussed here and pi
zero goes to plus e minus
um uh is not a decay that can normally
happen
in the normal model of things
because of i think charge charge
conjugation parity if i remember
correctly
um is that right the other related decay
is pi zero goes to neutrino
anti-neutrino which i believe has now
been observed
but um uh pi zero the pi zero particle
okay now i'm now i'm just playing
particle physicist here but but um
this is from my distant past but the pi
zero
um uh decays in about 10 to the minus 16
seconds
into uh two photons it's kind of a
famous source of
of of two sort of photons that because
of the pi zero is at rest for momentum
conservation the two photons
go out back to back so to speak and
that's some
uh anyway the the pi zero's most common
form of decay is is is photon photon
um those protons can each turn into a
either one of them can turn into
electron positron pair
so that ends you up with a gamma and an
e plus e minus
or two e plus c minuses um
but a single e plus c minus can't happen
uh
according to
i think that's yeah i think it violates
parity of charge conjugation and
variance
which means that it can't happen as a
result of so so normally when you're
producing photons that's through
electromagnetic processes
that's how the pi zero decays uh sort of
particle physics trivia
the lifetime of the pi plus and pi minus
is like 10 to the minus eight seconds
so the lifetime of the of the pi zero is
much shorter than that
because the electromagnetic interactions
are much stronger than the weak
interactions
so they lead to a shorter uh they lead
to sort of more rapid
decay um and the question is could you
also have weak interactions contributing
to some
decay modes of the pi zero and that's
what i think you have to have to get
well you certainly have to have it to
get
pi zero goes to neutrino anti-neutrino
because nucleo only does weak
interactions it doesn't do
electromagnetic interactions
because it doesn't have a charge okay
long long story here but but
um uh the um
uh yeah that's that's about as much as i
could um um
could say about this i i wouldn't uh
just based on
my history of knowing about particle
physics
and physics experiments in general i
would not be running around
saying there's a there's a major new
kind of force in the universe based on
this experiment so far
i i think you have to wait a bit um
these experiments are really hard
and um it's uh it's um
uh both the experiment is hard in this
case and i i don't know
the the predictions from the standard
model are probably reasonably
straightforward in this case
um but i i since i only just learned
about this i haven't looked at them
but uh so i wouldn't know whether there
was a possibility of of uh
a mistake like you know like isaac
newton's mistake and
in predicting the motion of the moon
based on his theory and uh you know you
shouldn't conclude his theory is right
or wrong based on that because there's
kind of a stack of things that have to
be calculated
um to work out the actual effect all
right
i better wrap up here and i realized
that there were a bunch of people asking
about the history of lisp
i promise i will get to that next time i
had hoped i would get to that this time
um very different topic we ended up
talking a bunch about physics today
um and uh that's some
uh uh i hope
um people found that interesting it was
uh it was a lot of fun for me to
uh think again about
weak decay processes because i last
seriously thought about those things
about 41 years ago so um
thanks a lot and actually i am about to
do
another live stream that's part of my
day job
uh doing uh language design for the next
version of language
so um and next week in this slot
i will be doing a business and
innovation q a and the week after that i
expect to be doing another one of these
and i will talk about lisp at that time
okay
thanks